[Music]
my name's brian
this is my infamous inventions pantry
it's actually a cow shed
things went a bit topsy-turvy in my life
i was very alone
ah fiddlesticks that's when i just
started making stuff
any little idea i had i just made it's
an egg belt pine cone bag flying cougar
clock so whenever anyone in the village
wants to know the time they can look up
in the air and i'll be there
they don't always work and the stuff i
build isn't for everyone i'm impressed
thanks
my new project i'm building a robot
didn't look too bad does he i wonder
what he'll do when i turn him on
would you like me to give you a name
tony
charles
charles
charles charles you like that name do
you hello brian hello charles it's
lovely to meet you
this is incredibly overwhelming imagine
me and you i do
i never thought i'd make anything as
amazing as charles you built my body
and my tummy is a washing machine and
his tummy is a washing machine so happy
together
you show them to people
what you want for them
oh he's not forced
i feel pretty cool man
imagine i want to go on an adventure
everything is lovely it's not all lovely
stay down boy there's a big old world
out there the big perilous world
what was that okay so
i want to sit in the front ryan no
you're not sitting in the front sitting
in the back i will sit in the front
you'll sit in the back front stop saying
front front front front front
i've never met anybody that could build
a robot
[Music]
i'm not a child i can look after myself
man what's coming to you
i tend to learn from each thing and i
build
[Music]
i want to go to honolulu charles what
are you wearing it's my hawaiian hula
skirt
[Music]